[Música]
Brasil enfrenta una profunda
polarización política después de cuatro
años de la presidencia del
ultraderechista Jair bolsonaro la
izquierda regresó al poder de manos de
alucinación Lula da Silva y aunque lleva
menos de dos meses a cargo del ejecutivo
ya ha enfrentado varias tormentas como
el ataque a la plaza de los tres poderes
el ocho de enero ejecutado por
bolsonaristas además de las denuncias de
un senador quien afirma que el
expresidente bolsonaro intentó dar un
golpe de estado para permanecer en el
mando Mientras tanto el Antiguo
mandatario está en Estados Unidos y
sostiene que las elecciones en las que
perdió frente a Lula fueron un fraude
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
Carol prowner jurista y analista de
política y profesora de la universidad
Federal de Río de Janeiro quien
precisamente está en esta ciudad Además
nos acompaña desde Sao Paulo el
periodista hipólogo Paulo moura antes de
comenzar les quiero recordar a nuestros
televidentes que también son del debate
dejen todos sus comentarios y preguntas
a través de las redes sociales en
Twitter Facebook e Instagram nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24-raya al piso es y pueden
comentar con la etiqueta el debate f24
Mis cuentas personales las encuentran
con arroba María cl Aguirre no olviden
además que todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa están disponibles en
Apple podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
Ahora sí queremos comenzar con nuestro
debate sobre la polarización que existe
en Brasil y antes de esto un breve
recordatorio de que el 30 de octubre de
2022 fue la segunda vuelta en la que
Luis Ignacio Lola da Silva ganó la
presidencia del país sin embargo hubo
una profunda división Pues obtuvo solo
el 51% de los votos versus el 49% que
obtuvo bolsonaro bolsonaro atribuye La
derrota a la injerencia del ministro
Alexandre de morach quien además es el
presidente del supremo tribunal Federal
esto durante la campaña electoral quiero
darle la bienvenida entonces a nuestros
invitados Carol proner y Paulo moura
Bienvenidos a France 24 y Comencemos con
Carol Usted cree que es cierto que hubo
un fraude o es un poco un modelo copiado
de lo mismo que alegó el expresidente de
Estados Unidos Donald Trump
efectivamente el país Brasil empieza el
nuevo gobierno con mucha movimentación
política graves actos el día 8 de enero
efectivamente marcó la historia del país
la historia de de de de de la normalidad
democrática en Brasil y ha sido conocido
en todo el mundo como un día de
vergüenza en sentido de ataque a las
instituciones democráticas sin duda
ninguna
un ataque a los tres poderes a las
instituciones a las sedes no a los
edificios a los palacios de los tres
poderes en Brasil lo que es bastante
grave porque es una un efectivamente se
llevó a cabo algo que se había prometido
entre manifestantes apoyadores de Jair
bolsonaro que Ejecutan el resultado de
las elecciones del año pasado No desde
octubre Cuando se sale el resultado no
aceptan y el propio es presidente Jair
bolso no reconoce el resultado electoral
Entonces no imaginábamos que eso Sería
posible había amenazas de que podrían
llegar a vías de hecho no de evadir
Palacios Y eso es algo Bastante grave
porque de alguna forma está estimulado
por un discurso negacionista del proceso
electoral de las instituciones del
sistema electoral de las urnas
electrónicas de la Democracia del
supremo tribunal Federal del poder
judicial de modo general y también no
del sistema democrático en términos
constitucionales lo que es bastante
contaminado en términos de modelo
en toda América Latina y no solo en
Brasil y mismo Estados Unidos una vez
que el presidente bolsonaro es un
admirador y seguidor del trompismo del
trompismo de Trump en Estados Unidos
Carol usted menciona el ataque del 8 de
enero que luego vamos a analizar en
profundidad sin embargo menciona algo
importante y es un discurso negacionista
como el propulsor de estos ataques que
se verían posteriormente Le quiero
preguntar lo mismo a Paulo moura si
usted cree que hubo fraude o no o sí
como lo dice Carol se trata más de
impulsar un discurso negacionista
Bueno
yo creo que hay que separar lo que es
narrativa de lo que son hechos
y si se observa objetivamente
no solamente los resultados y el
discurso de Los Seguidores del
presidente bolsonaro pero las actitudes
del tribunal superior electoral en la
conducción de la elección se ve
claramente por la cantidad de decisiones
tomadas a favor de la candidatura en
contra la candidatura del consolar una
absoluta parcialidad no voy a entrar en
la discusión si
los números que salieron de las urnas
electrónicas
expresan o no expresan una fraudes para
mí hay que considerar un hecho de que el
presidente bolsonaro sufrió una
oposición sistémica cerrada en cuatro
años de gobierno fue acusado y golpista
durante cuatro años sin que haya ninguna
actitud que justifique
duponte desde tu punto de vista práctico
estas acusaciones no fue el presidente
bolsonaro que censuró periodistas que
mandó desmonetizar o cerrar
páginas perfiles sin miles sociales no
procesó siquiera ningún vehículo de
empresa ningún periodista
Quiénes hace estas cosas en Brasil es la
suprema corte y después el Tribunal
Superior electoral que el comandado por
tres jueces de la suprema corte Entonces
el presidente enfrentó una oposición de
prácticamente toda la prensa
del de una parcela expresiva del sistema
político de la máquina pública del del
boicote del del sector burocrático de la
máquina de estado incluso una oposición
internacional sin que en ningún momento
tenga tomado actitudes prácticas
para dar el tan hablado golpe de estado
y tu oportunidad
en siete de septiembre de 2021 cerca de
dos millones de apoyadores de
Presidencia fueran las calles
en siete setentas
presidente ya ya tenía cambiado los
comandantes militares el ministro de
defensa por generales que
se posicionaban contra un impeachman del
presidente al contrario del comandante
anteriores Y puso más gente a la calle
dos millones de personas solamente la
avenida paulista y hubo manifestaciones
masivas en todo el Brasil por tanto el
presidente tenía el apoyo de las fuerzas
armadas del ministro de la defensa que
fue su candidato avise después
de los tres comandantes militares y
tenía pueblo en arrúa y no se pasó golpe
ningún
Entonces yo creo que hay una narrativa
así como este roto lo de que pulsonar es
ultraderecha gustaría a mí saber lo que
es diferencia de ultraderecha de derecha
porque este es un rostro esta narrativa
oposición que el presidente recibió
al todo el mandato fue lo que llamo De
oposición sistémica porque no es una
oposición normal no es una oposición
partidaria en el parlamento es
prácticamente toda la prensa el sistema
judicial del país
además la supremas corte especialmente
varios jueces de la suprema corte y hay
que considerar que cerca de 35 a 40 por
ciento de los electores brasileños no
confían en el sistema electrónico
quiero interrumpir Paulo porque le
quiero hacer una pregunta usted hace
digamos toda una argumentación sobre que
hay una oposición sistémica y no se
trata de un golpe de estado
porque Jair bolsonaro cuenta con el
respaldo de las fuerzas militares gran
parte de las fuerzas militares y aún así
no hubo golpe de estado sin embargo Le
quiero preguntar frente al hecho de si
fue fraude o no Usted dice que el
tribunal supremo electoral claramente
estaba a favor de Lula sin embargo luego
hubo un análisis de nuevo de estas
votaciones que fueron recusadas por el
partido de bolsonaro y no encontraron
nada Cómo responder ante esto
No es que no encontraron nada
está errada esta visión lo que pasa es
que han pedido para asisar los juegos
conjuntos los códigos Fuentes del
programa hoy con Fuente del programa que
hace la contabilidad de los huecos de
los votos Incluso el Ministerio el
Ministerio de defensa fiscalizado
a confite del tribunal electoral la
elección y
la conclusión es la que para poder
comprobar que hubo o no hubo fraude
ellos necesitaban acceso al sistema a
verificar el programa de computador que
contabiliza los votos y no obtuvieron
respuesta
Alejandra Morales que es el presidente
del tribunal superior electoral ha
respondido diciendo que iba a considerar
lo que decían los militares para
perfilar el sistema para las próximas
elecciones y negó a eso a los códigos
Fuentes del programa y es lo que podría
probar Igualmente el partido de bolsonar
hizo una auditoría independiente llegó a
otras conclusiones sobre anomalías en el
sistema y pidió acceso para una
auditoría del sistema y no tuvo
respuesta Entonces no se puede afirmar
que hubo fraude pero no se puede afirmar
que no hubo también porque las personas
que demandaron el Ministerio de defensa
el partido bolsonar que demandaron
acceso al programa que contabiliza los
votos para una auditoría completa
eran como respuesta a una negativa de
las del Tribunal Superior
yo no afirmo que hubo fraude justo
porque no hay pruebas pero no hay
pruebas también de que no hubo y lo que
ha sí es pruebas de que
centenas de decisiones sobre procesos
encaminados por el partido de bolsonaro
al tribunal superior durante las
elecciones tuvieron respuesta negativa
del tribunal y al contrario las demandas
del partido de Lula de la campaña de
Lula al tribunal que se dieron a colida
era aprobadas es una desproporción de
des para uno a favor de Lula
quiero interrumpir lo quiero interrumpir
de nuevo y los voy a pedir que sean más
concisos con las respuestas Pues tenemos
bastantes puntos para analizar Le quiero
preguntar a Carol qué piensa de esto de
que no se puede afirmar que hubo fraude
pero tampoco que no lo hubo y que hay un
desbalance entre la recusaciones
presentadas por los bolsonaristas frente
a las presentadas por los seguidores de
Lula
Bueno creo que lo único que puedo estar
de acuerdo con mi batidor es el punto de
partida hechos no
la defensa de sus argumentos están todas
vaciadas en un victimismo que es el
argumento principal de Jair bolsonaro
cuando utiliza
ataques contra la suprema corte el
problema que los ataques no son críticas
en términos democráticos solamente son
estímulos estímulo a una oposición a la
justicia al poder judicial incluso
física y eso empezó cuando se instaló un
injerito para investigar hechos ante
democráticos y violación no del Estado
democrático de derecho y de la
estabilidad entre poderes y cuando fue
determinado por un determinado
presidente de la suprema corte Entonces
el designador fue toffoli que
diastófolie que desde lleno el el juez
alexan os enamoráis para conducir un
inquietud contraatos democráticos al
principio del año anterior el año
electoral fue el año pasado Entonces
desde entonces se acumulan hechos
antidemocráticos Y a partir de octubre
el propio expresidente
naturalmente está muy desagradado por
ser investigado es su condición actual
en este proceso que acumulativamente
reúne hechos y hablemos otra vez de
hechos y no de nativos como decía mi
opositor de batidora el periodista y si
no de que estamos frente a situaciones
que de hechos y amenazas se
transformaron en algo real no personas
estimuladas por el bozonarismo que es
una expresión que el expresidente no
quiere que utilice él no quiere ser
asociado a esa ilegalidad porque sabe
que está efectivamente frente a una
situación real de riesgo una vez que uno
tiene más la condición de foro pri
al principio de esta entrevista se
mencionaba como resumen que un senador
Aliado de sonado hizo una denuncia que
ahora está siendo acusado incluso de
falso testimonio denunciación
calumniosa Incluso cohesión en el curso
del proceso que es Marcus Dubai es un
senador conectado a Jair bolsonaro que
cambió Por lo menos cuatro veces versión
no sé si me va a preguntar pero es
importante vamos a hablar de eso y
quiero precisamente ir cronológicamente
y primero entender Qué pasó el 8 de
enero para luego sí hablar de la
denuncia del senador y disculpe que la
interrumpa porque aquí estamos viendo la
base de la división Y ustedes son una
representación de cómo está polarizado
el país porque basados en esta idea de
si hubo fraude o no han comenzado las
divisiones o se han profundizado mejor
las divisiones en el país tanto de un
lado si hubo un estímulo a los
opositores o si hubo una narrativa
contra bolsonaro y en medio de esto
después del 30 octubre en la segunda
vuelta la presidencial Los Seguidores
del expresidente Jair bolsonaro
acamparon frente a los cuarteles del
ejército en Brasil sobre todo en
Brasilia para pedir una intervención
militar y frenar el gobierno que se
venía de Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva la
pregunta que les quiero hacer es por qué
lo permitieron y quiero comenzar con
Pablo
permitieron porque la Constitución
brasileña que la suprema corte no
respeta porque este injerito a que hace
que habló mi debatedora es ilegal
espacial en una regla
internamiento interno
del de la suprema corte que dice que la
suprema corte solamente puede abrir en
créditos para actos que amenacen la
suprema corte dentro de las dependencias
de la suprema corte Por tanto la base es
de sus Inquietos todos que fueron
abiertos y no es uno solo son tres o
cuatro son todos ilegales no están
previstos en la Constitución porque el
juez Alejandra morais y Quienes se dice
acusado es el policía y es el juez de
una casa de una causa en quien se dice
amenazado entonces son inéditos ilegales
hablemos de hechos
el derecho de manifestación es
garantizado de la Constitución brasileña
Sí pero yo más que manifestación yo no
concuerdo con golpes militares tengo una
historia un canal con más de cien mil
seguidores en en YouTube donde tengo
vídeos en contra golpes militares y y
contra lo que hicieron este
manifestantes que adentraron los placer
y causaron depredación Pero ellos
le hicieron como acto de Suspiro porque
querían una auditoría el sistema
electoral y no tuvieran respuesta el
presidente bolsonar en momento algún y
desafío que proben que el presidente
estimuló esto el presidente mantuvo
silencio no en momento algunos incentivo
que la gente fuera acampar en los
cuarteles y mucho menos incentivo que
hiciera lo que hicieran invadiendo las
sedes del del de la suprema corte y del
Congreso alias extrañamente entraran con
mucha mucha facilidad y en eso para se
imagina que Estados Unidos tendrá
centrada en la casa blanca es más o
menos lo mismo Sí y aquí de hecho de
hecho es parecido es parecido en el
sentido es parecido en el sentido de lo
que ocurrió en enero también de 2021
luego de la victoria de Joe biden que se
tomaron el congreso esta toma también
del 6 de enero y al respecto quiero
entonces pasar la pregunta a Carol Pablo
habla de un acto de desespero de Los
Seguidores del presidente para exigir
una auditoría a este sistema electoral y
de hecho horas después de este ataque
del 8 de enero en la plaza de los tres
poderes donde se encontraban el congreso
el tribunal supremo el supremo tribunal
federal y la casa presidencial o la sede
presidencial después de esto horas
después el ex bolsonaro dio un mensaje
en el que rechazaba esto y negaba a
tener cualquier vínculo en ese aspecto
Por qué entonces adjudicarle este asalto
a la plaza de los poderes a bolsonaro Y
cómo justificar la visión de Lula de
hablar de un asalto y de un intento de
golpe de estado
no creo que sea posible justificar lo
que pasó el día 8 de enero estudiado en
todo el mundo como un grave
intento de golpe de estado como
fundamentar en acto de desespero de
parcela de de manifestación que son
absolutamente inexpresivos el número de
de población brasileña entonces
absolutamente
injustificable y evidentemente
considerando que muchos manifestantes
estaban armados había incluso Granada
armas de fuego no todos pero muchos
muchos fueron detenidos inmediatamente
casi mil personas etcétera y han sido
investigadas están siendo procesadas de
denuncias etcétera etcétera
depredación de los edificios públicos
Palacios en cualquier lugar del mundo en
cualquier en cualquier régimen político
eso sería responsabilidad y considerado
una evidente golpe intento de golpe de
estado por otro lado también hay una dos
cosas muy graves una minuta de de una
minuta de documentos preparatorio de
golpe de estado en casa es ministro de
bolsonaro que Anderson este esta minuta
está haciendo investigada con gran con
grande precisión por parte de las
autoridades judiciales y policiales no
Además eh un una minuta de decreto que
debería ser firmada por el presidente de
la república Y esta Life esta Este
programa antes de salir del país no en
que el presidente ha anuncia que en los
últimos tres meses o sea desde las
elecciones intentó encontrar una
solución para evitar la pérdida del
poder por fin como mencionaba antes de
ser de este término de debate de punto
de debate este senador Marcos Duval hace
una acusación muy grave y aunque tenga
cambiado cuatro veces de versión y
tendrá que responder por crímenes
previstos al código penal brasileño
ahora es también está siendo investigado
él Comenta de una reunión que
efectivamente ocurrió y hablamos de
hechos acá hechos con el es diputado
Daniel silveira que otro bastante
violento y también incluso está con
orden de detención y con una una prisión
domiciliar que siempre viola las reglas
bastante bruto en el sentido De no
respetar las órdenes judiciales además
de Marcos Duval en una reunión en que
eventualmente tenían discutido métodos
una alternativa de golpe de estado
bolsonaro puede haber sido puede haber
quedado en silencio como dice como dice
el periodista opositor de este debate
pero efectivamente
Él debería actuar como presidente de la
república para evitar cualquier
desequilibrio entre poderes e
instituciones y yo quiero decir una cosa
Yo no soy
partidaria en este momento quiero las
cosas muy bien Él es presidente Lula
actual presidente actual presidente
electo él ha sido condenado por la
justicia después los procesos fueron
anulados Pero en ningún momento el
expresidente negó aceptar decisión Del
Poder Judicial él puede haber contratado
abogado buscado argumentos para
defenderse pero nunca negó la la
institucionalidad de la justicia eso es
bastante distinto de una vez presidente
quien mega elecciones que niega el
sistema electoral y las urnas
electrónicas que que han sido
confirmadas por por varios órganos de
control electoral del mundo entero las
elecciones más controladas del de
nuestro sistema electoral hasta el día
de hoy y por lo tanto estamos acá frente
a instituciones del estado el presidente
de la república que nos respeta sus
propias instituciones y su propio
sistema electoral es bastante difícil
les voy a pedir les voy a pedir que sean
más concisos en las respuestas
lastimosamente de nuestro formato es más
corto de lo que quisiéramos quiero dar
un poco de contexto de lo que estaba
diciendo Carol y Es sobre el escándalo
de las declaraciones del senador Marcos
dobal que ante la revista bella de
Brasil le envió unos mensajes que el
propio Dual habría compartido con el
ministro Alexandre de moraesh en el que
supuestamente se reunieron bolsonaro el
exdiputado federal Daniel silveira uno
de los más Defensores de bolsonaro y que
se reunieron en el Palacio en el Palacio
do plan alto el nueve de diciembre de
2022 es decir 21 días antes de que se
acabara el mandato de bolsonaro
supuestamente
adobal le dijeron que se reuniera con
demoraesh para grabarlo ilegalmente y
hacerlo caer en una imprecisión para que
así el tribunal supremo electoral no
pudiera posesionar a Lula y bolsonaro
siguiera en el poder después de esta
denuncia se conoció a principios de
febrero el expresidente Jair bolsonaro
hizo un discurso en un evento en Miami
un evento programado por grupos de
derecha en el que él no se refirió a las
denuncias que está siendo dobal Y que
ahora está investigando el supremo
tribunal Federal Este es un poco el
contexto de lo último que ha ocurrido en
Brasil Le quiero preguntar a Pablo
qué posición ha tenido bolsonaro frente
a esto y cómo responder a estas
denuncias que ya pasaron a Lo legal
apoyador de bolso el senador el partido
podemos que es un partido independiente
que ahora oscila para un lado hora para
otro
recibió un convite para entrar en el
partido liberal que es el partido del
presidente todavía no sí confirmó y es
un personaje controvertido
Entonces está con una conducta que
merece mejor observación
el encuentro el supuesto encuentro del
presidente con el diputado Daniel
silvera y el senador no fue en el
Palacio de plan alto y fue en otro
predio público pero no fue en el Palacio
y parece
reside el pedido de audiencia de un
senador y un diputado
nos recibió lo subió y no se manifestó
estos son los hechos
Ahora quiero hacer un paréntesis con
relación a gestión de la libertación de
luna que es otro absurdo la suprema
corte tiene siete juicios indicados por
el PT Lula había sido condenada en tres
instancias con las tres instancias
confirmadas por decisiones del tribunal
supremo y en un determinado momento
después de condenado en todas esas
instancias un juez indicado por Lula
decide anular el proceso porque entendió
que el foro original del proceso no
Debería ser la ciudad de curititiva y
pero sí San Pablo o bacila esto no
existe en ninguna parte del mundo
aquí lo interrumpo probablemente
condenado y fue libertado por esta
Suprema Corte que hace oposición
porque ya nos estamos yendo demasiado
atrás que es un poco también algo de lo
que está en debate sobre los juicios
quien además estuvo en la cárcel varios
meses y varios años precisamente acusado
de corrupción sin embargo no podemos
remitirnos hasta allí Porque
lastimosamente el tiempo no nos da Solo
dos precisiones yo nunca dije que el
doval fuera o el sonarista me refería
era a silveira que claramente sí ha sido
un Aliado de bolsonaro y por el otro
lado fue dobal en sus primeras
intervenciones ante la revista bella
quien dijo que la reunión había sido en
palacio do plan alto que es la sede del
ejecutivo sin embargo esta ha sido una
de las contradicciones que ha hecho
Duval quien después de que el caso se
hizo bastante mediático ha cambiado de
versión y una de las cosas que ha
cambiado es donde ocurrió la reunión
frente a estas
polémicas que han surgido después de
esto Le quiero preguntar a Carol Cuáles
han sido esas contradicciones de Dual Y
esto no le resta
validez a lo que está denunciando el
senador
en esencia lo que cambia en su discurso
es la propia involucración o no del
expresidente en actos digamos de
preparación para un golpe esencialmente
en la minucia Y ahora estás en
investigado justamente por falso
testimonio o sea por atestar fatos
hechos que no son verdaderos o bien que
sabe que no han sido ocurridos no
Entonces estás en investigado por eso y
como tiene cuatro versiones
contradictorias será bastante difícil
que se explique porque son cuatro
versiones que se anulan entre sí
Entonces es bastante difícil la
situación de Marcos Duval y creo que
quizás pueda ser incluso eh
presionado él mismo sufrir cohesión no
se sabe hay que investigar con bastante
Igor no bastante vigorosidad en términos
de debido proceso legal que es algo que
ha faltado Incluso en muchos procesos
que que hemos pasado en los últimos años
en esta situación y poder judicial en
Brasil pero importante entender también
que el poder que el que ahora en este
momento
no hay no hay un proceso contra el
presidente bolsonaro el expresidente
bolsonaro que por ejemplo que le
signifique un proceso de extradición o
mismo que él pueda ser preso detenido en
Brasil él es investigado pero no hay una
sentencia contra él es presidente
bolsonaro lo que hay son una
multiplicación de denuncias El
ministerio público federal Abre abrió
hace menos de una semana una
investigación para responsabilizar
agentes públicos por cuestiones contra
los pueblos indígenas hay acusaciones de
genocidio hay ya una denuncia contra el
expresidente bolsonaro y más 70 personas
crímenes contra humanidad que ha sido
aceptado por el tribunal Penal
Internacional la cuestión y los crímenes
contra los pueblos indígenas están cada
vez más
investigados por todas las instituciones
en Brasil el propio supremo tribunal
Federal hace una investigación el
ministro
bajoso que que es uno de los ministros
que está a frente de este tema más
ambiental y indígena Entonces está
bastante complicada la situación de
responsabilización de las autoridades
públicas que han actuado de una forma
muy grave contra los derechos humanos y
pueblos en particular pueblos indígenas
la situación Por tanto por lo tanto de
bolsonaro ya son más de 40 diputados en
Estados Unidos en contra de la presencia
de Jair bolsonaro y territorio americano
haciendo conferencias incluso
recibiendo dinero o sea que también
desvirtió un poco la situación del visto
turista que él ejerce o busca cambiar en
este momento está en Miami haciendo
conferencias pagadas etcétera entonces
todo eso significa que a cualquier
momento puede ser denunciado por
crímenes Incluso en Estados Unidos y
sufrir un
para que vuelva a Brasil en proceso y
aquí para hacerle un par de precisiones
está en Orlando Florida sin embargo ha
dado discursos en en Miami tal como
usted lo ha dicho y está allí desde el
30 de diciembre un día antes de que
acabara su gobierno y dos días antes de
la posición de Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva y de hecho el sonaro no estuvo
presente en la toma de Mando de Lula y
desde entonces se ha quedado en Estados
Unidos y como usted dice ha pedido una
visa de turista para poder permanecer
más de seis meses en este país Le quiero
preguntar muy brevemente a Carol y luego
hacerle la misma pregunta a Pablo Carol
por qué estaba el expresidente bolsonaro
en Estados Unidos
él está habitando correctamente no Miami
sin Orlando en casa de un conejillonario
de un apoyador en un condominio del jugo
en esta en esta ciudad y y tiene ahora
la intención de cambiar de visado ahí
hace conferencias sobre todo con
brasileños que habitan en esta ciudad y
está también influenciando hoy es
considerado mundialmente eso es un hecho
uno representante de la extrema derecha
en el mundo O sea que hay una
preocupación por sus jumbos con su
conducta no solo en Brasil es un un
símbolo no de una política que llamamos
a política de la negación de las
instituciones del estado y la
legitimación a través de un victimismo
como si estuviera siempre perseguido no
por los poderes por las instituciones y
ese discurso político un tipo político
Ah Y que que se que está también
presente y países de Europa también
Estados Unidos
hoy es considerado por muchas personas
de la política y de los otros partidos
políticos como algo algo peligroso
contra la democracia Entonces quiero
quiero interrumpirla porque quiero darle
también a Paulo la posibilidad de
responder porque esta bolsonaro en
Estados Unidos y según Carol Entonces lo
está para promover este símbolo de la
ultraderecha contra las instituciones
usted está de acuerdo con esto
Bueno hay declaración de hoy es la
empresa brasileña
afirmó que votaría a Brasil en las
próximas semanas para liderar la derecha
ante el hecho de que no ve otras
lideranzas capaces de hacer oposición
yo creo que soy estoy interpretando no
no no no no tengo la versión de bolso
porque está allá en primer lugar yo creo
que está porque dice distanciarse del
país en el en los primeros meses del
gobierno de Lula dejar abrir lo que pasa
dejar la la o se dice en portugués
el polvo bajar al suelo clarear el
escenario y a ver lo que va a hacer
cómo está amenazado de prisión como está
implicado en injeritos ilegales debe
estar avaleando la situación jurídica y
las condiciones que tiene devolver al
país sin ser preso interpreto que pueda
ser varios de sus motivos pero suele
solo solo él le puede responder esta
pregunta con propiedad Porque
solo interpretando sus intenciones y que
se puede
intentar entender lo que yo le llevó a
Estados Unidos claro Pablo y la última
pregunta ya a manera de resumen en todos
estos enfrentamientos quién cree usted
que gana más bolsonaro para reivindicar
su figura como expresidente perseguido o
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva como y
reivindicar su discurso de que bolsonaro
está intentando dar un golpe de estado
muy muy temprano ahora para hacer una
evaluación más más segura más precisa
hay que dejar el tiempo dejar el el
presidente Lula seguir
su política económica que está
confrontando inclusive más parcial de
Mercado que le he apoyado está sufriendo
un desgaste por decisiones económicas
que toma hay perspectivas de alta de la
inflación de queda el crecimiento
económico
deterioración del escenario económico
Lula ha recibido y esto se está dando un
responsabilidad en la actual gobierno de
las decisiones que anuncia y del
discurso que hace Lula entonces creo que
con el pasar del tiempo en se
confirmando esta situación hoy salió una
encuesta de opinión con la primera
variación del gobierno no ha perdido
ocho puntos porcentuales de esas
elecciones
necesito interrumpirlo necesito
interrumpirlo aquí porque quiero también
esa pregunta un poco para cerrar por
parte de Carol muy brevemente Quién gana
entre Lula y bolsonaro frente a todo lo
que está ocurriendo
yo creo que no hay que buscar oposición
entre un personaje político y otro se
nos he construido institucionalmente el
país hemos tenido un proceso electoral
ha sido validado por sistemas de
observación electoral de todo el mundo
incluso Naciones Unidas incluso oea y
creo que hay que respetar el resultado
de las urnas dejar gobernar hacer
críticas la que sean pertinentes en cada
caso pero no hay una necesidad de oponer
parte política y partidariamente contra
el país el país de las instituciones no
pueden pagar un precio de una oposición
nativa como decía
Pablo Mora esta esta situación creo que
no es válida nos tenemos que detener en
la reconstrucción democrática y que el
culpa universalía adversarial político
siga su normalidad incluso posiciones
válidas y legítimas y creo que ahí
debemos apostar nuestras fichas
democráticas caro proner y Pablo Gracias
por estar con nosotros en el debate de
France 24 y hasta aquí nuestro programa
pero sigan con todas las noticias en
nuestro canal
[Música]